hey everybody it's Casa de Laura with e
team we are hanging out with Blake
Shelton backstage at his I Heart country
buddy release party I'm so excited to
talk to you and sit down and you know
talk about your new album
congratulations I mean it has been two
years since your last album and here we
have fully loaded what do you want fans
to know about this album well I think
they mostly already know everything
about the islands only one thing that
they haven't heard and it's a it's a
duet with Wynn and I that's it but I
think by the time they even see this
interview it'll be out there so I guess
the one thing that I would say is you
know after all these songs of mine that
you've heard for the last you know three
years now it's it's a quick and easy way
to get all of them it's pretty much it's
pretty much a hits package you know but
we put nobody but you on there and
there's another one called Jesus got a
tight grip I'm drinking songs anytime I
have to offset oh my god religious songs
within drinking pill right I got a bad
reputation to uphold around a bad
reputation to uphold it's so interesting
that because Mac and me you told us that
you may never release a full-length
album again and that you loved releasing
singles but here we are another album do
you think this is gonna be the final one
I have been exposed as a liar
thank you but you're the first one to
just address the elephant you know what
I don't know I didn't expect us to do
this this makes more sense to me because
it's it's basically a greatest hits
package for the last you know five years
or four years or something and I've had
two other Greatest Hits packages that
come out so and I don't know if we're
gonna do an album now because when I
think of an album like a studio album
definitely have enough songs recorded
and you know that we're holding off in
the can or whatever but I don't know I
it makes sense on one hand on the other
hand that every day that goes by it
seems to make less sense I think to do
much more of a right and release method
I'm just releasing the song once in a
while and you know keeping the fans
excited and I think once you release an
album people these days are they want
something new all the time you know and
once you release the album in a week
none of those ten or twelve songs are
new anymore you know so I don't know
what I want to do to be honest with you
it's just I've just been looking forward
to this one particular interview with
you because this is where we really get
down to the good stuff
oh we blink I got so many questions for
all let me tell you but you know
obviously this album has already been
successful because the title track gods
country has not only earned you like
you're 26 number one but also your 8th
Grammy nomination in your career what is
your mindset going into the Grammys you
know I think I kind of just chalked that
up to that window had passed me by and
my career you know and so I didn't
expect it really be nominated for a
Grammy ever again you know and unless
it's like 30 years from now and you know
some kind of a weird things come up but
honestly it's it just shows you the
power of the rock yeah three and a half
minutes you know God's country is just
such a you know monster single and and
it would have been for anybody I was
just to get lucky enough you know to get
my hands on it and you know it's just
been a hell of a ride and the Grammy
thing is a shocker the CMA thing was a
shocker for me I was just I was just
glad to have a you know another song
that had impact like that no matter how
it got celebrated I cannot believe
though that you have never won a Grammy
it blows my mind it's like always the
bridesmaid never the bride I'm hope I'm
keeping my fingers crossed at this thank
you how much you vote please vote for me
come on oh there you go on the ballot
Blake Shelton and I'm sure you'll have
Glenn by your side on a night oh yeah oh
yeah well speaking of her I have to tell
you Blake the duet nobody but you the
first time I listened to it I wept this
song was so powerful it's so deep also
makes me feel very single but a first
time that you to listen to the final
track
I mean who who cried more well when was
crying it well when we even just talked
about singing it together at all you
know and actually got the song through
Gwyn because she had been working with
Shane mcanally and and he told her that
he had a song he needed to get to me and
send it to her first and then she sent
it on to me and and I listened to it and
I knew that I my god I gotta cut this
song songs incredible and and about the
time I was deciding I needed to cut it I
was also imagining what it would be like
as a duet it wasn't written that way but
it just seemed to fit perfectly with
with her our story yeah and and
musically I think it walks the line of
what I can do and what she can do and it
just everything just kind of aligned and
came together and it's one of those
once-in-a-lifetime you know moments and
pieces of music it's very very very
beautiful and very powerful I mean the
lyrics will like cut your heart but
unlike the most beautiful way especially
because it's a song that talks about
knowing what you have in your life while
you have it and not wanting to let it go
I mean when did you know Gwen was the
one for you it didn't take long you know
I had known when from working with her
on the voice the first season that she
works there but it didn't really know
where I was literally about like I know
you it's like and then and then by the
time the second time she came around you
know are both of our lives that
basically fallen completely apart and
and little did we know it happened to
both of us at the same time and we
bonded over that and then you know it's
so somewhere in that you know that time
of just you know darkness was this ended
up being the greatest moment of my life
you know so it's just it's amazing it
truly is and one thing about your bond
that I love and respect so much which we
see in this song is
your faith is evident and as a woman of
faith myself that is probably my
favorite aspect of this song and you've
been very open about how Gwen has you
know increase your own belief and God
how would you say faith has made you to
stronger together as a unit well I think
both of us know that the timing and the
way that she and I met and came together
and it just felt like home that's that's
not an accident you know and and I think
just the way that she and I were able to
to save each other's lives and get
ourselves through that at that time
there was evidence to us that God had a
hand in it you know and song okay
answers your question like Drake says
God's plan that's right now I have to
ask you and I know the fans are
wondering too is there going to be a
music video for a nobody but you
absolutely I mean I'm not going to
listen there's no way I'm going to have
a duet with Gwen Stefani and not because
part of what's great about Gwen is she's
incredible singer but the are the part
that's appealing is she is drop-dead
beautiful and if I can have her on my
video people actually look at the video
for once in my entire career you're damn
right we're gonna do a video do you guys
have a creative visual for it yet a
little bit you know I think it's one of
those songs that the song feels timeless
to me and so I think we've got to treat
the video that way it needs to be you
know classy and iconic feeling and and
that's what we're gonna try to do and
we'll see it I've still got a few weeks
to get on the treadmill and so turn a
certain learn how to suck in a double
chin if anybody out there can figure
that out
please Twitter Google com may have some
answers No
Gwen's boys were they kind of made a
cameo and I'll name the dog okay can we
get them on board for this music video
cuz it's such a personal song I think it
would fit five do you want to keep it to
just YouTube well I'm sure that those
kids are hams even they would love to be
right up in the middle of the
camera but the two mission issue for
them probably yeah probably the first
time they can see us you know kiss or or
even hug oh my god let's get out of here
so I mean my what I'm looking forward to
the most is how you bring the lyrics to
life like I said there are so many
powerful lyrics my favorite one that I
know people are gonna talk about is I
don't want to look back in 30 years and
wonder who you're married to him
you're not helping the rumors legs
you're not helping them I will say that
I love the rumors rumors are great
anybody that thinks that you know that
I'm married to win already is I love it
my god who wouldn't want to be married
to win stefani lucky man right there I
will say one last thing about the song
because I do love it so much is I do
think it is on par with John Legend's
all of me like I literally think people
are gonna put it on their love songs
play less and it's gonna be one of those
songs god I hope you're right I you know
and I've said this before at this point
in my career I'm I'm recording the songs
that I want to record and and with the
people that I want to record them with
and just whatever happens from there is
what happens and and and so far that's
been the best career move that I've made
is kind of almost taking my eye off the
ball and just doing what feels good in
my heart you know it started with God's
country and and and now here we are
going into this thing with with with
Gwen and had I'm just having a blast
right now you're living your best life
you're living your best life I love that
Blake Shelton thank you so much for
letting us come here buddy
backstage with you at your I heart
country album release party for fully
loaded gun country by the way look at
that come on come on I can hook you up
with some Smith thank you thank you
[Music]